before I jump to the second derivative
let me just address a question that came
up in the break which is just the the
nature of the the nature of the
parameters that you might see you know
here I might know that there is very
little change if I change X a little bit
but here I know that if I change X a
little bit there's a lot of change okay
and that you in problems like let's say
climate change that comes up all the
time so one of the standard topics is G
here is the greenhouse gas concentration
in the atmosphere and this might be the
damage and damage here is broadly
defined it could be economic damage or
it could be other kinds of damage the
question might be well does it look like
that does it look like this or does it
look like that okay and so clearly what
really matters here is what's the slope
or what's the derivative of the damage
function close to where we are and so
all kinds of analysis is done to try to
determine whether the slope looks like
this or it looks like that or it looks
like that and
so much of the debates surrounding the
costs and benefits of carbon dioxide
mitigation really hinge on whether you
think that the damage function looks
like this or this or that okay okay now
the the second derivative so we all
understand what the first derivative is
if you think of the first derivative not
just as a slope but as itself a function
of X then you might want to know well
how does this function of X the first
derivative how does its slope behave
okay in in this example here is a
function f of X I took its first
derivative and that first derivative
happens to be a straight line I could
ask well what what how does the slope of
this first derivative behave and you'd
probably have an easy answer right it's
just a straight line the slope of this
first derivative is everywhere constant
okay and so it would actually look like
anybody want to take a guess parallel to
the x-axis is this correct or wrong
wrong okay it's negative right so it
should be something like that why is it
negative because it's done with sloping
okay so this is f prime prime of X ok so
this well this is the second derivative
that is this is the slope of that slope
and that is the slope of that okay so
this function is the slope of that
function and this function is the slope
of that function but this function is
itself a slope yes
no it's just because I've shown you a
relatively simple initial function here
that its first derivative was a straight
line and because its first derivative
was a straight line its second
derivative was a horizontal line if I
yeah if I went back to that the crazy
function its first durable its first
derivative looks a little bit more
complex than that actually it's even
more complex than this if I were to take
a derivative of this then I would get a
function that's still nonlinear and that
too would have its own derivative and
that might still be nonlinear and so on
okay in a sense the the amount of
differentiation the number of times you
have to differentiate to get to a
straight line is a measure or a metric
of the non-linearity of a function you
know so when you see away when you're
going to do your science classes or your
climate classes and so on you'll hear of
highly nonlinear functions highly
nonlinear when when we say highly or not
so highly that's determined by the
number of times that you'd have to take
a derivative to get to a straight line
okay
yeah most functions if you kept taking
derivatives you'd get very close to a
straight line not it wouldn't ness if
you take functions that we can imagine
in some random way not function that
we've constructed specifically to be
pathological you know then if you just
took some random functions that we
constructed you can almost certainly say
that in a finite number of steps you'd
of differentiation you'd get to a
straight line but you can also construct
pathological functions which don't
converge to a straight line easily and
that's those are the kinds of functions
that are used in crip in encrypted grams
in encryption because one of the ways of
carrying out encryption is to look for
derivatives of underlying random
functions yes you know sorry what's your
name again Kathy right Kathy is is going
to be labeled as the philosophical one
in your class because because she's
always giving me imponderable questions
but but so that's a it's a deeply
philosophical question as to whether the
functions that we see in nature are
complex because we because there's noise
and that noise creates complexity or
because nature itself is complex and we
don't know we don't know all the
variables that affect it so it looks
like noise to us but actually if we
worked out or if we knew all the
variables that affected it it wouldn't
look like noise at all but that's beyond
the scope of this certainly this session
ok so then what you want to know is the
second derivative of a function
is the derivative of the derivative of
the function okay so it's a function
that gives you the slope of the
derivative or the slope of the slope and
it also has its notation F double prime
X is the most convenient one but you'll
also see d squared Y over DX squared or
d squared f of X over DX squared okay to
denote that and you'll see a third
derivative too sometimes generally you
will not see the third derivative in in
economics but you will see it quite a
lot in biology and climate science and
engineering okay I haven't yet shown you
what convexity in concavity mean but
just keep in mind that by definition for
differentiable functions if the second
derivative is positive then the function
is convex if the second derivative is
negative the function is concave and you
don't you'll see what that means in a
second okay okay so here is a concave
function okay it's very common to see
both students and instructors become
confused about what's concave and what's
convex part of it is that a concave up
function is also referred to as a convex
down function so and that terminology
comes from pure mathematics so we we
tend not to use that usually in
applications this is referred to as a
concave function that's concave up so
generally in these applications you if
it says concave it means concave up
and usually what that means is that the
greater than set the greater than set
which is this set here is concave okay
so you can try to remember that we
concave up means that the greater than
set is concave or you can just get
internalize that this is a concave
function okay okay now what is concavity
a differentiable function f is concave
if its derivative function its slope is
monotonically decreasing that means it's
always decreasing concave function has
decreasing slope okay let's go back and
look at this concave function here it's
upwards steeply upwardly sloped here
it's still upwardly slope but more
shallow so it's slope while always
positive is becoming smaller okay so
that is a concave function slope is
always decreasing and okay convex
function is just the opposite slope is
always increasing okay so what's going
on here up here the slope is steep but
negative so this is the slope here is a
large negative number let's say minus
aight here it's probably closer to minus
1 so its slope goes from minus a 2-1
that means its slope is increasing here
its slope is 0 and here its slope is
positive so slope is always increasing
for this function it's a convex function
ok ok an alternative definition that you
will see of concavity and convexity has
to do with intermediate points is this a
concave or convex function concave right
for a concave function if you take two
points along the x-axis let's say X 1
and X 2 and you evaluate the function at
those points
you draw a straight line joining you
draw a straight line joining the two
values of the function that straight
line will always lie below the function
itself ok that's a concave function and
you could if you like to do logical
proofs you could play around it's not a
difficult proof to show that this
definition of concavity will is
equivalent to this definition of
concavity ok I'm vice versa for
convection but that shouldn't be your
primary focus in this program ok but
this is a useful thing to keep in mind
actually the reason I'm telling you this
is not for you to do a proof but because
you'll find that this this idea or this
mathematical definition actually has
quite a practical application and you'll
see that when we start doing economics
but it has to do with the values of
averages so here it for a concave
function the function evaluated at some
average of x1 and x2 is always going to
be higher than the average of the
functions yeah that was quick for a
concave function the function evaluated
at an average of x1 and x2 will always
be higher
then the average of the function of x1
and the function of X 2 and and that
will that'll turn out to be a very
useful application property when you
deal with things like risk and its
evaluation and and other applications to
okay yes yeah so this so think of let's
say this is the average of x1 and x2
it's at the midpoint let's say okay then
this is f of X 2 this is f of X 1 and
this is f of X of X bar which is the
average and this ok this is this is the
average i'm using excel notation here
okay so that average of the functions is
always less than the function of the
average right for a concave function yes
the average of the functions okay that's
this the average of the functions is
always less than the function of the
average that's the function of the
average that's the average you go up
till you hit the function that's the
function of the average and this is the
average of the functions because this is
the function here that's function here
and that's the average right and that's
the definition of a concave function hmm
the secant yeah the secant here is
always below so you know and when we
went if you go back and look at that
that secant line tangent line thing
you'll see that that was a convex
function so the secant line was always
above okay okay okay now so we're going
to jump into the technical part of this
the differentiation rules but before I
jump to that I want to make sure that
you have at least an intuitive grappling
I don't you don't have to have a grasp
but you have to have an intuitive sort
of grappling with the idea of a slope a
derivative doesn't really matter about
the second derivative too much okay if
you get that then that's that's a lot
and in general the way that you know of
course the way knowledge is constructed
if you under
then the the simplest twenty percent of
the material then you understand eighty
percent of the problem and if you and
you generally spend a lot of time
understanding the last twenty percent of
the problem but when you learn you
should try to make sure you spend eighty
percent of the time understanding the
simplest twenty percent okay so now this
part is really all mechanical and in
real applications you probably won't use
it that is if you have a very
complicated function well you're going
to ask your computer software to
determine its derivative you know
whether it's MATLAB or octave or or your
computing derivatives numerically and if
it's really simple the only reason that
you need to learn to take a derivative
is for exams and we all know that exams
are not going to be your determinant of
success in the endeavor that you've
staked out for yourselves but so there's
a lot of slides here but I'm going to
take you through them relatively quickly
but stop me if if you want to okay but
some basic rules you do want to
internalize that is functions of course
might be sums of many different terms
and as such when you differentiate you
can generally take the sums of the
derivatives that is if you have a
function that's the sum of two functions
it's derivative is going to be the sum
of the two derivatives that is you could
take a derivative of each function and
add them together and you'd get the
derivative of the original function so
and you'll see you'll see well actually
that's probably the next rule the first
rule is you can take each term you can
you can try to take a derivative of each
term at a time and the derivative of a
constant you already know is 0 right the
slope of a constant is 0 a constant
function is a horizontal line it has
zero slope ok ok so another rule when X
is raised to the power of one that then
the slope of the coefficient on the
slope is just a coefficient on that X
right so if Y is equal to 2 X the slope
of 2 X is just too and what's the slope
of 15 0 so the slope of 2x plus 15 is 2
plus 0 ok Rule three when X is raised to
some power n greater than one but an
integer then to get the slope you pull
out the coefficient this this sounds
more complicated than it really is you
pull out the co-efficient you multiply
that by the power of X you multiply that
term by X and you carry it to the power
n minus 1 you know if i read that i'd
have no idea what that meant but but if
you have done even a little bit of
calculus you'll remember that you know
that the derivative of x n is n X to the
M minus 1 ok and that's all of that says
so you can see that sometimes sometimes
it's easier to speak in mathematics than
in English
sorry right right which is the reason
for this okay which is why you want to
spend three hours before Labor Day
weekend doing this okay so what's the
slope of 5x cubed plus 10 well I guess I
gave you the answer there so so that's 3
times 5 is 15 times X to the 3-1 okay so
that's 15 x squared and then the
derivative of that is 0 okay how many
for how many people is this completely
new a few of you right okay so what what
I want you to do is to make sure that
you come and talk to me afterwards or
rather actually send me an email and
I'll make sure that we spend time
separately that's going to be a
obviously a small group like half a
dozen people suddenly in my class I
and/or a TA will spend time to help you
do that because it's just it's obviously
not something you'll learn in five
minutes and and you shouldn't try to do
it do it that way okay but the little
bit that you will need to get used to
for problem sets or four for exams very
little in most exams I give you very
simple if any differentiation problems
I'll generally even give you very good
hints but just for the little that you
do have to do you have to you should let
me know so that we can spend some time
and so that you have enough to get
through and get to the intuition this
learning this is not your purpose in
life okay hopefully that's clear to
everyone